[Musique]
en nous confiant publiquement à quel
point leur sevrage de la politique a été
pénible
[Musique]
c'est tellement difficile de trouver une
raison de vivre ma carrière Maryse
Gaudreault et marcollène ont rouvert la
plaie de plusieurs autres ex élus comme
l'ancienne ministre Lucie Charlebois
mais oui je suis juste humaine
dévasté par sa défaite inattendue en
2018 après 15 ans de service politique
nous l'avons joint en Floride 4 ans et
demi plus tard
[Musique]
ici elle tente de retrouver des passions
comme le piano ou le golf pour
s'éloigner de l'alcool une dépendance
qui l'a développée après sa défaite
de vous l'annoncer au plus bas elle nous
confie s'être retrouvé en haut d'un pont
je dois me blesser
[Musique]
France Dionne et Manon Blanchette deux
anciennes députés en ont entendu des
témoignages du genre au Cercle des ex
parlementaires cette association réclame
un plus grand soutien psychologique mais
aussi financier on n'a pas de chômage
pourtant on a travaillé
contrairement à la croyance populaire
plusieurs d'entre eux peinent à se
retrouver un emploi parce qu'ils sont
identifiés à un parti
c'est pourquoi le cercle des ex
parlementaires demande à l'assemblée
nationale de l'Europe Troyer deux
semaines supplémentaires de salaire en
plus de la location de transition le
temps de fermer les dossiers de
circonscription en ce moment un comité
se penche déjà sur l'augmentation du
salaire de base des députés alors
pourquoi ne pas utiliser ce moment-là
pour travailler sur deux d'autres
dossiers connexes appelons ça comme ça
le cercle réclame aussi une transition
une voie rapide vers un emploi supérieur
dans la fonction publique puisque les
élus connaissent mieux la machine que
bien d'autres candidats est-ce qu'on
réalise justement cette connaissance là
cette expérience là est-ce qu'on est
capable de l'apprécier autant cette
expérience là peut justement servir
certainement dans l'appareil public il
ne fait aucun doute pour elle qu'il
faudrait bonifier le montant annuel de
850 dollars pour soutien psychologique
[Musique]
Charlebois confirme que l'Assemblée
nationale s'est beaucoup penchée sur le
sort des excès lu dernièrement mais il
faut continuer selon elle en fait
et ce même si l'opinion publique n'est
pas toujours favorable alors cause ici
Véronique prince Radio-Canada Québec